ببدر في انتظار وصول المسيره كما ذكرنا
كيف تبدو الاجواء في محيط ستاد لوسيل
وماذا عن حضور الجماهير السعوديه حتى الان
[موسيقى]
كما شاهد حمزه الجمهور السعودي المنتشر في
محيط ملعب الحسين واكيد الارجنتيني
الجمهور السعودي جاء من كل مدينه تقريبا
سالتهم جميعا السعوديه حاليا الجمهور
يستمتعون بالاجواء خارج الملعب بلا هذه
الصور بالالتقاء ايضا من الجمهور الجنسيه
وعمل حوارات معهم همم معنا جمهور سعودي
مختلف المدن معنا الاخ همم
مكه اليوم ان شاء الله مبارك قويه مع
الارجنتين السعودي
احنا نتمنى ان السعوديه اليوم تؤدي اداء
انت هتلعب مع كوكب من نجوم العالم همم
التوقع صعب والنتيجه في علم الغيب ولكن
نتمنى انه المنتخب السعودي اليوم يؤدي
اداء يبيض الوجه ويرفع الراس
من باذن
[موسيقى]
يوم الجمعه بصراحه استمتعنا بكافه العظيمه
وافتتاح الكاس العالم ستوري تشكر عليه قطر
همم الجميع من مبسط هنا تنظيمات رائعه
اجواء حلوه همم
نطمئح تقديم مباراه حلوه اليوم رغم
صعوباتها ان شاء الله انه نقدها ان شاء
الله اني قدها اليوم مسي يا رب يكون اصابه
قالوا اصابه نتمنى ذلك انه ما يلعب هو
اللي صراحه خايفه منه
[موسيقى]
جاي من الخبر
طيب اخي الكريم توقعاتك اليوم لمباراه
النتيجه والله لو متفاعلين ما جينا من
السعوديه بس باذن الله باذن الله ان شاء
الله اليوم السعوديه قدها باذن الله لن
اغلب اللاعبين الموجودين الحين كلهم
يلعبوا 2018 يمكن 09/10 لاعبين واخذوا
الدرس من روسيا باذن الله المباراه اليوم
تكون متفائلين زياده والله
ويرفعوا الراس باذن الله ويقدم مستوى جميل
ان شاء الله خساره فوز كلها رياضه كلها ان
شاء الله الله يعافيك السلام عليكم يعطيك
العافيه انا والله من لبنان مشجع السعوديه
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله الربح من نصيبهم
يا رب ان شاء الله يا رب لو واحد صفر
حايل من السعوديه
وجايين نشجع المنتخب السعودي بكل حماس
بتفائل ان شاء الله
مباراه ضد الارجنتين قويه واتمنى نقدم
مستوى
يليق بسمعه السعوديه
فالمنتخب الارجنتين فريق كبير بس اتمنى
المستوى النتيجه لا تتوقع النتيجه
[موسيقى]
قطر كاس العالم هذا اهم شيء تنظيم خليجي
عربي هذا اهم شيء
على فكره
كماشات حمزه الجمهور السعودي منتشر ولو
اتيت لو خرجنا قبل ساعات كان قبل ثلاث
ساعات تقريبا جمهور موجود في موعد الملعب
جميعهم الان يتجهون بالقرب من الدخول الى
ارض الملعب
للمدرجات ولكن ما نشاهد ايضا هناك الكثير
من الجمهور يقادمون وفي هذه الحاله نتوقع
ان يكون الملعب ان يتسع الذي يتسع ل 800
متفرج ان يكون ممتلئه كما اا سمعنا في
الايام الماضيه جميع الملاعب الثلاثه التي
شهدت المباريات كانت سعتها مكتمله وواصل
رعد الجمهور حتى الان الى 130,000 متفرج
في المباريات في اليومين الماضيين حمزه
يتوقع المباراه قويه من كل تاكيد بين
المنتخب الارجنتيني ويتمتع بنجوم كبار
وكذلك السعوديون يظنون ان هذه المباراه لن
يكونوا خصما سهلا ويسعون الى الفوز
وسيعتمدون على نقاط القوه التي يملكونها
وسيحاولون قدر الامكان ان يت- يعني يقوموا
بالعناصر الضعف التي لديهم